at a certain point I felt my sense of
self begin to crumble I looked out and
saw myself
explode into a cloud of blue Post-it
notes
if you imagine a manuscript being blown
away by the wind you would run around
trying to gather it back together and
and I felt No need no desire to collect
all those Post-it notes before they flew
away in the wind it was like fine go
you've served your purpose
wowie well in the Netflix docu-series
how to change your mind author Michael
pollen explores the history and use of
psychedelic drugs among them psilocybin
commonly known as magic mushrooms though
still illegal almost everywhere many now
see great potential in such substances
to address mental health issues and
that's put them on the ballot in
Colorado Barry Peterson reports
America's last great experiment with
hallucinogenic drugs in the 1960s
launched a Counter Culture Clash of
generations
kids rebelled parents recoil
this time around it's about the quiet of
This research clinic at Johns Hopkins
University where psilocybin is tested Dr
Albert Garcia Romeo is assistant
professor of Psychiatry and Behavioral
Sciences I think psilocybin seems to be
very promising as a potential treatment
for a number of different conditions for
depression for Addictive disorders that
would include things like alcohol
dependence cocaine dependence opioid
dependence tobacco use psilocybin a
psychedelic compound found in magic
mushrooms can change a person's
awareness of their surroundings and of
their thoughts and feelings once we get
a little bit more data I think we'll be
able to put it out there where people
will be able to receive those types of
treatments are you optimistic this will
pass I'm incredibly optimistic we have a
lot of support across the state Kevin
Matthews isn't waiting for more data he
is Coalition director of natural
medicine Colorado that helped get
psilocybin's legalization on Tuesday's
Colorado ballot he used psilocybin for
his own depression folks who experienced
major depression usually have a lot of
regret about the past and so it it
released the burden of those regrets and
enabled me to be
completely present with my experience
right now like you and I are talking in
this moment ten years ago Colorado voted
to legalize marijuana for recreational
use now there are pot shops across the
state but if voters legalize psilocybin
here as it has been in Oregon people
over 21 won't buy it at stores they
could grow small amounts of mushrooms
for personal use or go to licensed
Healing Centers to use it with a monitor
present Tracy T has already taken
psilocybin mainstream studying about it
extensively and then founding moms on
mushrooms in Denver where psilocybin is
already the lowest priority for law
enforcement being in the mama Sphere for
10 years and watching the struggles that
women deal with we come from a culture
that expects you to do everything be
Superwoman and have a smile on your face
the entire time moms who are struggling
with their mental health share stories
about how or why Tony amount to
psilocybin called micro doses can help a
lot of moms don't feel present because
they feel called to their phones they're
getting text messages all the time
they're working from home they're
raising kids and our brains feel very
fragmented and psilocybin especially
micro dosing tends to quiet all of that
down so that you can focus more and have
more clarity and you can just say no to
all those external stimuli and just
focus on the now but the effects of
micro dosing have not been
scientifically researched I mean it's
possible but it you know it's hearsay at
this point it's just purely anecdotal
psilocybin is a federal schedule one
drug like heroin or LSD but the FDA has
now designated psilocybin a breakthrough
drug for research purposes but that does
not change Jeff Hunt's opposition to
legalization he is director of the
Centennial Institute at Colorado
Christian University these kind of drug
entrepreneurs are going well we can take
it to the The Ballot Box and get General
people who have no expertise in this to
say that it's okay and then we can
eventually commercialize it and make a
lot of money on it we got away from the
snake oil salesman and that's why we
have the FDA so in your mind the process
is backwards yes with with Ballot Box
Pharmaceuticals yes absolutely magic
mushrooms have been used for Centuries
by indigenous peoples but some like
Renee Millard Chacon say the groups
trying to make it legal are stealing
Native American Heritage they completely
go over us and over our sovereignty so
again they're another predatory
capitalistic behavior that is coming to
exploit specifically our medicines
without any form of restoration or care
about the communities at the impact now
Colorado voters must decide if they want
this ancient treatment for the mental
illnesses that Alice in these modern
times
for CBS Saturday morning Barry Peterson
Denver
it's interesting the point that was made
one of the guy's issues was that they're
taking it to voters yes instead of the
FDA really interesting I I just think
it's it's it's kind of a double-edged
sword here you have drugs on the market
like Ritalin and Concerta that help in
the same ways kind of calm people down
allowing them to focus for things like
ADHD but you know what's the difference
According to some of these doctors who
are claiming hey they can help right
this is also a natural ingredient
they've used it it heard a lot of
anecdotal stories of people dealing with
PTSD also as well the idea at least that
they can research with it because it's
been designated as a breakthrough
potential therapy at least now they can
study it as well